the alt-right as such has indeed greatly
faded from public View
its views haven't gone away and it has a
legacy inside of Mega trumpism the
question we are now left with is will it
survive another election cycle or will
the boberts and the Marjorie Taylor
greens and Trump himself
suffer a 2024 defeat that could be the
final nail in the coffin for this
roughly decade period is what it will be
at the end of the day eight years ten
years roughly 11 years depending on when
you consider the start of alt-right will
alt-right die
as part of Mega trumpism in 2024 that's
the question that remains to be answered
and one we're going to continue asking